one of the great loves from Paul  McCartney's life is Linda I didn't  realize Linda was you hired her to to uh  be a rolling stone photographer she said  I want to go meet Paul McCartney I want  to photograph him and you say instead of  saying hey I better not send this  stalker over to me Paul you say go go  and meet Paul and God bless I mean  you're like a Matchmaker she was like  the backbone of the Rolling Stone photo  library then she had all these old  pictures to take and then one day she  said I want to go cover the Beatles I  said well we don't really need to spend  the money you know sending you to London  why do you want to why do we need more  beetles so he says well I want to meet  Paul  that's okay you got the assignment go  wow and then I started getting postcards  from her every couple of weeks saying  you know how she's getting closer then  finally got one saying we went out last  time at night and had the most wonderful  time thank you forever